guten tag willkommen zu zdf heute live
lange war sie erwartet worden teilweise
auch gefordert worden die reise des
bundeskanzlers in die ukraine und nun
ist es soweit olaf scholz ist gemeinsam
mit frankreichs präsident makro und
italiens ministerpräsident raggi in die
ukraine gereist hat dort einige dinge
sich angeschaut vor allem ja man muss
sagen dinge die niederschmetternd sind
zerstörungen innerhalb der stadt kiew
beziehungsweise im vorort ich bin dazu
später noch mehr bei uns in der sendung
damit wollten wir eigentlich anfangen
aber die pressekonferenz nach dem
treffen der drei staats- und
regierungschefs mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky läuft bereits und
wir wollen direkt rein hören was dort
gesagt wird und anschließend dann alles
weitere zum tag des bundeskanzlers in
der ukraine
guten tag
erklärt anwesende damen und herren
ich freue mich heute den
ministerpräsidenten tragen der
ministerpräsident den präsidenten mit
rumäniens den präsidenten frankreichs
den bundeskanzler deutschlands begrüßen
zu dürfen wir schätzen befreundet sehr
dass sie heute hier sind heute im
vorfeld einer so wichtigen entscheidung
eine entscheidung für ganz europa
wichtig ist
und es ist ein wichtiger tag ich freue
mich dass sie sich eher peanuts
besichtigen konnten sie konnten mit
eigenen augen was russischer okkupanten
in unserem land und mit unseren menschen
angerichtet haben
unsere verhandlungen haben heute noch
einmal bewiesen dass unsere größte kraft
die kraft der einigung ist die einigung
an der alles andere liegt
als sie in kiew an kamen konnte man eine
sirene in kiew hören
in den meisten gebieten der ukraine
konnte man diese luftalarm führen und
das zeigt dass russland gar nicht welt
wann man das land beschießt und man
fällt nicht wenn man in russlands
perfekten wenn man in europa sicherheit
schenkt die russische aggression ist
gegen jeden gerichteten alle gemeinsamen
werte und
dementsprechend muss auch unsere antwort
ausfallen die ukraine kämpfen an der
vorderen front gegen russische
kämpfen und das wird durch unser treffen
bestätigt wir haben uns heute sehr gut
verständigt es ging um die verstärkung
der ukrainischen verständigung
verteidigungsfähigkeit ich bin allen
parteien für die schritte dankbar wir
heute abgestimmt haben wir haben auch
darüber gesprochen wie wir
wirtschaftlich dänische bürger und
ukrainischen staat unterstützen können
darüber wie man die ukraine nach dem
krieg wieder aufbauen kann wir haben
darüber gesprochen wie man der
nahrungsmittelkrise die von russland
angesetzt wo ihr begegnen kann
wir haben darüber gesprochen wie man den
ländern afrikas und asiens helfen kann
weil dieser länder oder nahrungsmittel
da stehen wir haben auch darüber
gesprochen wie man
muss den druck auf russland erhöhen kann
ich habe meine partner darüber
darüber informiert wie die lage an der
front aussieht über die situation in
hagen ich habe auch über täglichen
raketenangriffe
informiert die anzahl der raketen die
auf die ukraine auf das auch die ziele
der bevölkerung ausgerichtet wurde
beträgt etwa 3.000 stück die meisten
reagierten schon auf zivile objekte
abgeschossen ich habe über unsere
bedürfnisse im verteidigungsbereich und
verliert wer erwarten neue lieferungen
von schweren waffen von luft
schutzsystem und anderen anlagen
verteidigungsanlagen das würde helfen
ukrainische leben zu retten
das würde uns helfen unsere städte zu
schützen es gibt eine direkte direktes
verhältnis hier mehr waffen dir bekommen
umso schneller können wir unsere
menschen und unser tor befreien die
meisten ukraine warten darauf dass wir
unser land befreien können wir haben
auch über diplomatische beziehungen
gesprochen
die erforderlich sind um den frieden
wiederherzustellen
wir sehen dass das größte hindernis die
fehlende bereitschaft der russischen
föderation ist reale verhandlungen zu
führen die auf die wiederherstellung des
friedens gerichtet werden da ist
natürlich nichts bis auf den krieg jetzt
wo ich hier im marien palast sind jetzt
sind die russischen streitkräfte
eine grausame offensive in den bass
fort sie beschießen
man muss verstehen man muss in russland
verstehen es gibt keine alternative zum
frieden aber heute konnten wir die
sirene hören und man sieht dass russland
nur nach neuen möglichkeiten sucht um
europa angst einzujagen und immer
größere territorien der ukraine
einzunehmen sehr geehrte damen und
herren russland versucht die ukraine zu
brechen und dadurch auch ganz europa zu
brechen russland will zeigen dass die
europäische einigung angeblich nicht
fähig ist effizient zu handeln das
europäische werte nicht fähig sind denn
die freiheit zu schützen wir müssen aber
dieses szenario brechen und beweisen
dass alles anders aussieht es ist
wichtig vereins zu bleiben wir müssen
unsere integration die ukrainische
integration in die eu muss unterstützt
werden
wir brauchen eine positive
anstrengungen
das könnte historisch die freiheit in
europa stärken
ich glaube daran dass diese entscheidung
zu unserem starken historischen erfolg
es ist klar dass der weg in die
europäische union ein weg ist er nicht
ein jahr in anspruch nehmen wird aber
das wäre der anfang und wir müssten
handeln so dass unser staat zu einer
vollwertigen eu land wird die ukraine
haben es verdient diesen weg zu gehen
und den beitrittskandidaten status zu
erlangen wir haben gesehen dass die
meisten
bürger in der europäischen union die
europäische integration der ukraine
unterstützen wir haben den tiefsten
stand der unterstützung des ukrainischen
beitritts
wir haben heute auch über neue
sanktionen gesprochen
die erforderlich sind damit der frieden
wieder hergestellt wird das 17
sanktionspaket muss abgestimmt werden
und wir werden dann auch darüber
sprechen wie die ukraine nach dem krieg
wieder hergestellt wird das werden wir
auch weiterhin nach unserer
pressekonferenz weiter besprechen wir
werden auch darüber sprechen wie die
verluste die durch russland zugefügt
wurden
zurückgezahlt werden unser staat
arbeitet sehr aktiv daran wir haben auch
darüber gesprochen wie man die
nahrungsmittelkrise auch der welt
aufhält die ukraine macht alles damit
unsere häfen entsperrt werden aber
dieser blockade muss durch russische
streitkräfte durch den russischen
gresser eingestellt werden
wir
haben darüber gesprochen wie man
ukrainischer
ukrainisches getreide ausführen kann ich
bin mir sicher dass dieser besuch von
unseren freunden nach kiew
zur geschichte zu einer wichtigen seite
in die geschichte der ukraine und der
geschichte europas wird ich bedanke mich
für die entscheidungen zugunsten der
verstärkung der verteidigungsfähigkeit
der ukraine und europas vielen dank
wolodimir seelands geht dem präsidenten
der ukraine ich fasse kurz zusammen ist
ein wichtiger tag für die ukraine es sei
gut dass die staatsgäste sich die
grausamkeiten von pin auch mal mit
eigenen augen angesehen hätten um das
geschehen auch besser verstehen zu
koennen man habe sich verständigt gut
verständlich es ging um die verbesserung
der ukrainischen verteidigungsfähigkeit
dazu kommen wir dann später noch aber es
ging auch um die lösung der globalen
folgeprobleme und darüber wie man den
druck dann auch auf moskau gemeinsam
erhöhen können es sei wichtig verein zu
bleiben man brauche eben positive
antworten nun von der eu und darüber
können wir jetzt auch noch mal sprechen
mit julia held unserer reporterin vor
ort in kiew julia du hast die äußerungen
des präsidenten auch gehört die sind
diese einzuschätzen ist lenski mit den
ergebnissen der gespräche zufrieden was
ist dein eindruck
ich finde erst mal interessant zu sehen
diese pressekonferenz hat anderthalb
stunden gedauert das ist tatsächlich
ungewöhnlich lang und es ist überhaupt
nichts nach draußen gedrungen alle
journalisten waren aufgefordert ihre
handys abzugeben es ist wirklich gar
nichts raus gesichert diese
pressekonferenz wurde dann auch erst
verzögert ausgestrahlt gestreamt so dass
wir jetzt auch wirklich gerade erst die
informationen dazu bekommen und die sind
doch tatsächlich relativ konkret würde
ich sagen wir haben es jetzt gerade auch
gehört es ist das entscheidendste
wahrscheinlich einfach der beitritt
status der der ukraine und der republik
moldau in aussicht gestellt wurde oder
versprochen wurde dann hat makro neue
waffensysteme neue artillerie systeme
versprochen außerdem habe die
ukrainische seite habe der ukrainische
präsident seelands gehen nochmal neue
sanktions forderungen an russland für
russland übergeben auch das sei ein
wichtiges thema gewesen ich finde alles
in allem sind das doch jetzt recht
konkrete ergebnisse und ich könnte mir
vorstellen das waren ja auch die
forderungen die gestellt worden waren
von ukrainischer seite dass sie doch
recht zufrieden sein könnten vermutlich
wir werden gleich auch noch das
statement des bundeskanzlers hören ich
krieg dann hoffentlich ein signal wenn
das dann vorliegt vielleicht noch kurz
zum hintergrund organisatorisch wir
kriegen das alles mit einem gewissen
zeit versatz sozusagen mit wir können
also nicht ganz live dabei sein
vielleicht kannst du das gerade noch mal
erklären woran liegt das
alle diese besuche von ausländischen
staats und regierungschefs von
ausländischen politikern laufen unter
einer erhöhten sicherheit unter einem
erhöhten sicherheits und jetzt ganz
besonders natürlich wenngleich so viele
staats und regierungschefs auf einmal
kommen das ist aber tatsächlich das land
befindet sich im krieg im kriegszustand
da dürfen keine informationen
weitergegeben werden auch wir
journalisten sind angehalten alle
informationen immer erst dann
weiterzugeben wenn der programmpunkt
sozusagen abgeschlossen ist das ging
heute morgen los bei der ankunft an der
grenze beim einstieg in den zug alle
diese sachen durften immer erst
verkündet werden auch der besuch in ihre
bienen dann der besucher mit dem oder
das treffen mit dem präsidenten alles
das durfte immer erst dann verkündet
werden wenn es eben schon vorbei war und
das ist einfach eine sicherheitsmaßnahme
dauert damit sollen mögliche anschläge
verhindert werden
vielleicht gerade noch mal du hast
vorhin angesprochen die konkreten
ergebnisse die in der tat ja dann doch
relativ deutlich waren aber vielleicht
auch nochmals zum atmosphärischen drum
herum also die tatsache dass sich die
staatsgäste die ruinen von angeguckt
haben welche symbolik kataster einer
meinung nach dass man also mit eigenen
augen sich ebendort diese ja auch
vermeintlichen gräueltaten dann noch mal
angeschaut hat denn im vorfeld gab es ja
immer wieder die kritik dass gerade auch
aus deutschland dass der kanzler sich
immer etwas und empathisch zeigen würde
war das vielleicht auch das richtige
signal jetzt in dieser situation
er ist gab tatsächlich auch im vorfeld
viele gespräche unter journalistinnen
und journalisten hier ob es diesen
besuch denn geben wird weil olaf scholz
ja im vorfeld mehrfach gesagt er will
keinen fototermin haben und daher war
tatsächlich die überlegung ob er so was
überhaupt macht ich glaube aber
tatsächlich das ist ganz ganz wichtig
war und dass das von den menschen hier
auch erwartet wurde und dass eine große
hoffnung darein gesetzt wird dass er
sich tatsächlich selbst ein bild von der
situation vor ort macht wenn man sich
hier in kiew aufhält dann ist es von dem
krieg tatsächlich nicht sehr viel zu
spüren wenn man aber auch wirklich nur
eine halbe stunde raus fährt dann sind
diese ortschaften komplett zerschossen
da steht kein stein mehr auf dem anderen
kein haus neben dem anderen das da
erlebt man wirklich was hier vorgefallen
ist welche welcher welche aggressionen
diese menschen hier um welchen leid
diese menschen hier wochen lang
ausgesetzt waren und das ist glaube ich
ein großer unterschied ob man sich nur
hier in kiew auffällt oder ob man vor
ort sieht was tatsächlich da passiert
ist und insofern glaube ich dass es
wichtig war sowohl für die politiker
sich diesen eindruck selbst zu machen
aber auch für die menschen hier zu sehen
dass sie dort waren und das und das
gefühl haben dass das vielleicht auch
etwas an ihrer einschätzung der
situation ändert denn gerade olaf scholz
wurde hier ja als der unparteiische
wahrgenommen die letzten monate und die
hoffnung ist eben dass das jetzt
vielleicht was bei ihm ändern könnte
die einschätzung von julia held aus kiel
vielen dank für den moment und wir
sprechen mit brigitta triebel sie ist
von der konrad-adenauer-stiftung und sie
ist leiterin des auslandsbüros in
kharkiv uns allerdings gerade nicht aus
rates zugeschaltet wenn ich das sagen
darf guten tag frau triebe
kontakt
ja wir haben gerade schon über die
bisherigen ergebnisse gesprochen der
beratungen vielleicht auch gerade noch
mal als expertin von ihnen die
einschätzungen wie konkret wie zufrieden
glauben sie sind vor allem insbesondere
die ukraine mit dem bislang verhandelten
also ich denke auch die ukraine
ukrainerinnen sind sehr zufrieden mit
diesem besuch aber verein mit diesen
doch wirklich sehr konkreten ergebnissen
also der
eu-beitritt status dieser
kandidatenstatus in aussicht zu stellen
von diesen sehr wichtigen eu mitgliedern
die heute zu besuch ist ein ganz ganz
wichtig für die ukraine genauso wichtig
ist die ankündigung weiterer
waffenlieferung und natürlich ist es
wichtig wie ihre korrespondentin eben
schon gesagt hat dass diese
regierungschefs vor ort sind dass sie
diese zerstörung diese vernichtung in
der ukraine mit den eigenen augen sehen
und das hat sowohl in den konkreten
ergebnissen aber auch symbolisch ganz
ganz viel bedeutung für die ukraine und
wenn ich das hinzufügen darf ist das
natürlich auch eine klare aussage
richtung ausgang wie gesagt wir warten
noch auf das statement des
bundeskanzlers und sprechen aber bis
dahin gerne weiter mit ihnen morgen will
die eu-kommission ihre empfehlung
abgeben ob die ukraine den
kandidatenstatus der europäischen union
bekommen soll die 27 eu staaten
entscheiden dann allerdings auf dem
gipfel kommende woche ob sie der
empfehlung folgen wollen wie schätzen
sie momentan auch gerade nach dem was
wir jetzt gehört haben diesen prozess
ein mit welchem ausgang rechnen sie
also ich rechne da nicht dass es diesen
kandidatenstatus für die ukraine geben
wird es wurde ja auch angedeutet dass
man das moldau anbietet dass man auch
eine lösung den westbalkan findet das
ist ganz ganz wichtig dass die eu diese
ganze region im blick hat und ich gehe
davon aus ich hoffe dass die europäische
union hier diese entscheidung treffen
wird und dann auch einheitlich auftreten
wird das ist im moment für die ukraine
natürlich symbolisch sehr wichtig das
ist ein unglaublich großes zeichen der
solidarität der unterstützung werden
dieses land ja vor allem im donbass
gerade ganz ganz schlimme tage und
stunden zu erleben hat gleichzeitig ist
das aber auch ein entscheidender schritt
für eine demokratische und europäische
zukunft der ukraine nach dem krieg das
bedeutet für die ukraine eine
wirtschaftliche stabilisierung das
bedeutet eine aussicht auf ein besseres
leben und das gibt natürlich den
reformkräften innerhalb des landes auch
diesen aufschwung dass man nun all diese
notwendigen in ukrainischen reform
tatsächlich
umsetzen kann nebst diesen hebel des
zukünftigen eu beitritts rechnen sie
denn mit widerständen auch innerhalb der
eu oder glauben sie das geht jetzt
relativ glatt durch
da wird es sicherlich noch internen
diskussionen geben ich kann das nicht so
genau einschätzen aber ich denke doch
wenn die regierungschefs deutschland
frankreich und italien setzt die sind
deutliche signal in kiew senden ursula
von der leyen hat das ja auch noch am
wochenende als and ihr fall gemacht dann
hoffe ich doch dass wir nächste woche
auf dem gipfel auf dem eu gipfel dieses
positive zeichen erleben werden
gleichzeitig dürfen wir uns nicht nur
auf diese symbolpolitik verlassen
wichtig ist wirklich dass jetzt die
unterstützung für die ukraine weiter
konkret und schnell umgesetzt wird das
heißt also die waffenlieferung um die
ist gerade auch in der pressekonferenz
von seelands beginn müssen weiter laufen
vertriebe vielen dank bis hierhin wir
wollen gerade nochmal in die
pressekonferenz hinein hören denn der
französische präsident makro hat sich
auch geäußert
danke schön herr
präsident lieber wolodimir
liebe freunde liebe kollegen meine damen
und herren ich
danke zuerst einmal ein präsidentiellen
ski und über ihn dem ukrainischen folge
uns heute hier empfangen zu haben
und mit unserer präsenz hier in kiew
bringt wir den brüderlichen gruß der
europäischen völker an ein freies
souveränes volk zum ausdruck ein
heldenhaftes volk angesichts des
russischen angriffs sind voller
bewunderung und
wir versprechen unsere umfassende
unterstützt diese unterstützung genießen
sie hier präsident sie können auf uns
zählen
die ukraine kann mit uns rechnen auf uns
zählen europa hat von anfang an das
lager gewählt dass einer freien souverän
ukraine der achtung des völkerrechts
der verteidigung des der kartelle
vereinten nationen verankerten
grundsätze
den russland vorsätzlich
ungerechtfertigt und nicht zu
rechtfertigen es beschlossen hat zu
verletzen diese entscheidung für den
krieg die zerstörung das chaos der
bewaffnete überfall auf ein freies volk
all das können wir nicht akzeptieren und
werden wir niemals hinnehmen
mit den beispiellosen sanktionen liebe
beschlossen haben mit der umfassenden
wirtschaftlichen humanitären
und militärischen unterstützung die
jedes unserer länder in der europäischen
union die ukraine leistet und diese
unterstützung werden wir noch weiter
ausbauen damit also werden wir auf
unserem kurs bleiben und auf ihrer seite
bleiben und ihre souveränität ihre
territoriale integrität und ihre
freiheit zu verteidigen
das ist unser ziel ein anderes ziel
haben wir nicht und wir werden dieses
ziel erreichen
heute
geht es auf ukrainischem boden um die
sicherheit von ganz europa
das ist die erste botschaft die ich nur
einen kollegen über bringen möchte
europa steht auf ihrer seite und wird
dies so lange sein ist er sieger reicht
ist die rückkehr des friedens in ein
freies unabhängiges land ukraine
die andere seite wird die kolben der
barbarei zu tragen haben die wir heute
in wien gesehen haben
wir haben mit präsident selensky den
sofortigen im humanitären militärische
und wirtschaftlichen bereich besprochen
frankreich ist natürlich auch dabei um
darauf einzugehen wir haben bereits
milliarden dollar für
wirtschaftliche unterstützung
bereitgestellt und werden das weiter tun
die lieferung von vier geräten vor allem
von caesar geschützten die an der
bessere abwehr gegen die angriffe der
russischen armee ermöglichen auf dem
boden der ukraine all das zählt dazu
seit dem ersten tag hat frankreich
seine verpflichtungen opel haft
eingehalten genau beachtet und wir haben
auch schnell alles umgesetzt denn wir
wissen das
gerät schnell nötig ist dass es auf
geschwindigkeit ankommt und deswegen
haben wir entsprechend ihren
vorstellungen und wünschen geliefert
werden dass auch in den nächsten wochen
weiter so handhaben
die werden auch unsere maßnahmen
fortführung damit die kriegsverbrechen
die auf ukrainischem boden begangen
worden sind und die ganze welt hat das
erlebt nicht ungestraft bleiben
recht und völkerrecht müssen obsiegen
frankreich hat schnell an die tatorte
spezialisten entsandt die zu die
ermittlung der sachverhalte beitragen
werden ich habe präsident gefahr hin
mitgeteilt dass bald ein mobiles die
dna-analyse labor von uns geliefert
werden wird um die arbeiten zu
unterstützen um jede form der
straffreiheit anzukämpfen andere
europäische staaten sind ebenfalls dabei
und wollen diese unverzichtbaren
arbeiten mittragen und
die internationale gemeinschaft will
hier das licht bringen in die
unvorstellbaren dingen die sich jeder
ukraine zugetragen haben das erinnert an
die finstersten stunden unserer
geschichte um wir verlangen dass hier
das recht sich durchsetzt das zweite
thema das wir gemeinsam besprochen haben
ist die lebensmittelsicherheit die
weltweite nahrungsmittelkrise die wir
erleben ist eine direkte folge des von
russland geführten krieges andere
erklärung dafür gibt es nicht ich möchte
daran erinnern dass die sanktionen die
von den europäern
ergriffen worden sind russische
agrarprodukte nicht betreffen
wir möchten daran erinnern dass russland
gegen den sicherheitsrat gehandelt hat
und verhindert das getreide exportiert
werden kann
wir verlangen die aufhebung der blockade
der ukrainischen hilfen durch die
russische marine und verlangen alle
sicherheitsgarantien für die ukraine
damit
diese
abtransport des getreides möglich wird
auf initiative des chors der vereinten
nationen haben die ebenfalls gehandelten
theoretische kollege hat daran erinnert
wir müssen jetzt eine resolution des
sicherheitsrates der vereinten nationen
haben und russland hat sich bisher
dagegen gewandt ich hoffe dass sich
russland der bald um gesinnt jedenfalls
tanken präsident johannes für seine
bemühungen die werden auch noch weitere
wege beschreiten
wir denken auch an die donau und gehweg
über rumänien
wir haben gemeinsam unseren willen
bekräftigt durch taten die über die
worte hinausgehend zu belegen dass die
ukraine zur europäischen familie gehört
die unterstützung der europäer im krieg
ist offensichtlich
in gewisser weise
haben wir ja alle
messen wie brüchig der frieden ist den
wir nach dem zweiten weltkrieg erlebt
haben und wir sehen uns noch schmerzlich
an den letzten großen krieg und an die
erfolge möglichen aufbauwerk dieser
krieg hier wird die geschichte europas
ändern wir werden auf der seite der
krise stehen um sie bei diesem
europäischen perspektive zu begleiten
genau dies im kreis 21 auf dem gipfel in
der zeichnung getan haben das werden wir
gemeinsam den präsidenten einigen tagen
ab morgen eher kräftigen
europäische kommission wird morgen den
rahmen der diskussion abstecken wichtige
entscheidungen werden der nächste woche
in brüssel im rat getroffen werden
in jedem fall unterstützen wir den
beitrittskandidaten status der ukraine
für den sofortigen beitritt zu wischen
union in der prozess abgelaufen ist wir
haben auch eine roadmap dafür vorgesehen
und dabei ist an die lage auf dem
westbalkan ebenfalls zu denken und
insbesondere an die benachbarte republik
moldau moldawien
die werden in den nächsten tagen
gemeinsam die einstimmigkeit der 27 für
den so wichtigen europäischen gipfel
anstreben
mit unserem besuch und dem austausch mit
ihr geführt haben ist eine deutliche
geste ergangen der schnelle und
erwartete geste über die hoffnungen und
die klarheit die wir hier in der ukraine
auch für das ukrainische volk schaffen
wollen wir müssen über diesen weg der
jetzt begonnen hat und der italienische
ministerpräsident
und formen finden um kurzfristig
antworten zu finden auf
die die ukraine ein anrecht hat weil
sicherheit bei der infrastruktur und bei
vielen anderen aufgaben die ukraine
teilt unsere demokratischen werte ist in
dem gleichen kontinentaleuropäischen
raum und wir müssen deshalb auch
möglichst bald im rahmen der
längerfristigen prozess diese
perspektive eröffnen meine damen und
herren wir
streben den frieden auf unserem
kontinent an das ist alles nicht ohne
weiteres gegeben im muster verkämpfen
während hier der krieg tobt mit vielen
toten jeden tag mit vielen strecken
jeden tag und all das habe ich präsenten
zu letztlich schon gesagt während
unseres regelmäßigen vertraulichen
austausch
während dieser zeiten tun wir alles
anbieten die ukraine allein ihren weg
wählen kann denn es liegt bei der
ukraine bei ihrer führung bei ihrer
vertretung bei ihrem volk selbst zu
entscheiden
dieser grundsatz hat mich seit beginn
des krieges geleitet und bei jedem
gespräch mit ihnen
die auch jedes mal finde ich mich mit
dem russischen präsidenten gehalten habe
habe ich das im auge behalten die
ukraine wird in dem richtigen augenblick
entscheiden wann die bedingungen erfüllt
sind um einen frieden anzustreben
das gilt auch für die politische zukunft
des landes herr präsident ich möchte
hier sagen seit ihrer wahl habe ich
immer wieder festgestellt
dass sie
den frieden wahren wollen die krieg
verhindern wollen dass sie sich mit der
allem mut dafür eingesetzt haben dies
weiter tun wir möchten dass sie sich auf
die seite der grenze durchsetzen
wir erleben tragische umstände
der ukraine heißt es in ihrer hymne die
ukraine ist nicht tot wiederum noch ihre
zukunft sie können zählen auf die
brüderliche hilfe europas der mit die
ukraine weiter besteht danke
herr präsident ich möchte ihnen zunächst
einmal meine hochachtung aussprechen
die ukraine befindet sich seit 113 tagen
in einem heldenhaften abwehrkampf gegen
russland die tapferkeit der soldatinnen
und soldaten ist groß es ist
bewundernswert wie die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer sich gegen die invasion
russlands zur wehr setzen dafür lieber
herr präsident soll ich ihn soll
deutschland in großen respekt
gemeinsam mit seinem französischen
amtskollegen dem italienischen
ministerpräsidenten und dem rumänischen
präsidenten bin ich heute nach kiew
gekommen um ihm das auch ganz persönlich
außen zu drücken
klar ist dieser überfall auf die ukraine
markiert eine zeitenwende
in russland versucht mit gewalt grenzen
innerhalb europas zu verschieben
das ist unakzeptabel und
deshalb hat sich deutschland gemeinsam
mit vielen anderen ländern in der welt
vom ersten tag an eng an die seite der
ukraine gestellt
wir unterstützen die ukraine dabei ihre
souveränität und territoriale integrität
zu verteidigen finanziell mit hohen
zuwendungen die begeben humanitär indem
wir mehr als 800.000 geflüchtete in
deutschland aufgenommen haben um in
schutz und pro tag zu bieten
135000 kinder gehen inzwischen auf
deutsche schulen
von deutschland mit einer langen
tradition gebrochen wir unterstützen die
ukraine auch mit der lieferung von
waffen- und wir werden das weiterhin tun
solange die ukraine unsere unterstützung
benötigt
gerade irgendwie ukrainisches militär am
modernsten waffen aus an der
panzerhaubitze 2000 unter dem superb der
panzer gebhart
zusätzlich habe ich zugesagt dass
moderne flugabwehrsystem ihr system zu
liefern dass eine ganze großstadt gegen
luftangriffe verteidigen kann und das
spezial rada cobra
und wir haben nun gemeinsam mit den
vereinigten staaten von amerika und
großbritannien eine trilaterale
vereinbarung getroffen und werden der
ukraine mehrfach raketenwerfer geben sie
sehen deutschland unterstützt die
ukraine massiv
meine damen und herren meine kollegen
und ich sind heute hier nach kiew
gekommen mit einer klaren botschaft
die ukraine gehört zur europäischen
familie
ein meilenstein auf ihrem voraussetzung
reichen europäischen weg ist der status
eines beitrittskandidaten
darüber beraten die mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union in den nächsten tagen
wir wissen dass braucht einstimmigkeit
unter den 27 eu-ländern
beim europäischen rat werde ich mich für
eine einheitliche haltung staat machen
deutschland ist für eine positive
entscheidung zugunsten der ukraine
das gilt auch für die republik moldau
und es ist eine frage der europäischen
glaubwürdigkeit dass wir gegenüber den
staaten des westlichen balkan die sich
seit jahren schon auf diesem weg
befinden nun endlich unsere versprechen
einlösen jetzt und konkret
für den weiteren zur europäischen union
gelten klare kriterien die von allen
kandidaten erfüllt werden müssen das
gilt für die gemeinsam in der eu
vereinbarten regeln den akt insbesondere
mit blick auf demokratie und
rechtsstaatlichkeit
demokratie und rechtsstaatlichkeit sind
das was uns in der europäischen union
zusammen führt und von anderen
unterscheidet
abschließend möchte ich noch etwas
offensichtliches ansprechen die eu muss
sich auf diese entwicklung vorbereiten
und ihre strukturen und verfahren
modernisieren
meine damen und herren
in rheine soll leben
ich danke sehr verehrte kollegin
journalisten bitte ihre fragen die
deutsche
agentur
[Musik]
vielen dank michael fischer deutsche
presse agentur der bundeskanzler sie
haben vor dieser reise gesagt dass sie
hier nicht herkommen für fototermine
sondern über ganz konkrete dinge reden
wollen ganz konkret zu sagen machen
wollen wir haben das jetzt getan beim
thema kandidatenstatus
haben sie auch beim thema
waffenlieferungen zusagen gemacht da
gibt es ja eine lange wunschliste der
ukraine bis hin zu kampf panzern und
schützenpanzern
haben sie der präsident sie lenski
versprechen machen können und glauben
sie dass sie mit ihrem besuch heute
verloren gegangenes vertrauen
zurückgewinnen konnten in der ukraine
auch bei der ukrainischen bevölkerung
und herr präsident sie lentzke sind sie
zufrieden damit was der bundeskanzler
hier heute angekündigt hat
glauben sie glauben sie dass die
irritationen die es in den letzten
monaten gegeben hat zwischen deutschland
und der ukraine damit ausgeräumt sind
sehen sie deutschland jetzt als
verlässlichen partner und glauben sie
dass der bundeskanzler
tatsächlich will dass die ukraine diesem
krieg auch gewinnt
schönen dank für die frage ich will den
konkret noch mal darauf hinweisen
worüber wir gesprochen haben nämlich das
was jetzt in dieser militärischen
auseinandersetzung notwendig ist und ich
habe 13 mann presse statement gesagt
welche weitreichenden sehr modernen
packen wir zur verfügung stellen an
denen jetzt ausgebildet wird in
deutschland ich habe auch koffer
hingewiesen auf iris t sehr moderne
systeme um die lange nachgefragt worden
ist und die gemeinsame aktivität die wir
mit den usa und großbritannien im
hinblick auf mehrfach raketenwerfer
unternehmen das ist genau das worum es
jetzt geht die möglichkeit
verteidigung zu organisieren auch über
längere distanzen und genau das ist mit
all diesen waffen verbunden das sind die
die jetzt gebraucht wird
ich danke ihnen sehr für ihre frage ob
ich zufrieden bin mit der begegnung das
ist der erste teil ihrer frage ich bin
sehr zufrieden mit unserer begegnung
sage ich offen ich glaube das ist ein
signal zur unterstützung unserer ukraine
auch die geschlossenheit und der besuch
der führer aus europa dass diese signale
haben wir bekommen öffentlich als sie
uns getroffen haben und die
unterstützung und das habe ich bereits
in meiner ansprache gesagt ich bin
zufrieden dass unsere vereinigung von
der wir viel sprechen und wir sind der
meinung dass das sein soll ich habe das
heute an unseren verhandlungstisch
gesehen ich habe unterstützung von jedem
der hier anwesenden
politiker bekommen und deutschland ist
keine ausnahme diese unterstützung habe
ich vom bundeskanzler olaf scholz
bekommen ich bin zufrieden für heute ich
bin glauben dass deutschland und auch
der bundeskanzler wünscht dass der krieg
zu ende ist ich bin sicher dass auch das
gesamte deutsche volk die ukraine
unterstützt ich habe das gesehen ich
habe das auch gesehen als menschen auf
die strassen kann in berlin und in
anderen städten deutschland als sie die
ukraine unterstützen und dass sie gegen
aggression waren gegen die blutigen
krieg der von putin und
streitkräften der russischen föderation
begonnen wurde und ich glaube dass
unsere gemeinsamen kräfte wir die
russische aggression beenden können und
den krieg zu ende führen für uns sehr
wichtig diese und dinge dir herr kanzler
gesagt hat wie es den dankbar für die
lieferungen die jetzt laufen und wir
sind sehr sehr dankbar für die
flugabwehrsysteme und der
bundeskanzler hat das auch gesagt ihres
das sind alles für uns sehr wichtig
heute wurden zehn bis 15 raketen gegen
rob gegen friedliche objekte 10 15 gegen
und schulen kindergärten dass es ein
durchschnittlicher statistik jeden tag
werden so viele raketen gegen uns
abgesetzt wegen ist es für uns wichtig
flugabwehrsystem zu bekommen unser land
ist groß und deswegen brauchen wir diese
und hier wird uns deutschland sehr stark
dabei helfen bitte
also nochmal die antwort des doch
zufrieden wirkenden ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky zufrieden mit den
heutigen ergebnissen der gespräche zuvor
hatte schon frankreich in gestalt des
präsidenten seine unterstützung zugesagt
auch die unterstützung wenn es darum
geht dass die ukraine einen eu
kandidatenstatus erreichen soll und
ähnlich hat sich auch der bundeskanzler
geäußert er hatte noch mal betont was
für ein heldenhafter abwehrkampf es sei
denn die ukraine dagegen russland führe
allergrößten respekt hätte er davor denn
russland würde eben versuchen die
grenzen zu verschieben er sprach noch
mal von der zeitenwende das sei alles
vollkommen
inakzeptabel er hat noch mal darauf
verwiesen dass deutschland ja schon viel
unterstützung leiste sowohl was die
aufnahme von flüchtlingen angeht aber
auch die lieferung von waffen hat man
einmal aufgezählt flugabwehrsysteme
mehrfach raketenwerfer unterstützen das
alles sei schon in der vorbereitung bzw
auch schon vor ort und eben auch noch
mal das klare bekenntnis zur der
unterstützung was den kandidatenstatus
angeht wir sprechen über das gerade
gehörte noch mal mit bernd band ihn er
ist unser korrespondent im
hauptstadtstudio oder ist er bernd grüße
dich also wir haben da noch mal gehört
was olaf scholz gesagt hat wie sind
diese äußerungen nun innenpolitisch
einzuschätzen auch da steht oder stand
zumindest der kanzler in den vergangenen
wochen ja gehörig unter druck ja absolut
der druck war da und der war ja auch
zeit ein teilweise hausgemacht war so
olaf scholz hat ja gesagt dass wenn er
nach kiel fährt das er dann was
konkretes mitbringen will und wenn man
die pk jetzt hört man bei dass konkrete
zum einen die waffenlieferungen die ihr
da konkretisiert hat und zum anderen
eben diesen diesen ausblick des
beitrittskandidaten
und das ist das ob sich das jetzt wartet
das dass dieses signal was olaf scholz
setzen wollte ob das ausreicht das wird
sich noch zeigen in jedem fall ist es so
dass diese diese beitritts aussicht in
deutschland in den regierungsparteien
konsens ist also spd grünen und fdp
die wollen dass alle in europa
allerdings sieht es da schon anders aus
da gibt es schon zweifelt an den
verschiedenen stellen zum einen ist es
so dass eigentlich ein land der eu nur
beitreten darf das mitwisser
territoriale integrität aufweist und das
ist bei der ukraine ja schon allein
wegen der krim nicht gegeben das heißt
da gibt es juristische vorbehalte könnte
man sagen zum anderen ist es so dass
auch länder wie zb schweben vor bald
haben was die rechtsstaatlichkeit der
ukraine angeht das heißt das war jetzt
ein wichtiges signal drei große länder
der eu wollen das aber ist es noch
längst nicht ausgemachte sache und wird
dann in der kommenden woche spannend
wenn das in der eu gesprochen wird
vielleicht ein wort noch zum
beitrittskandidaten das ist jetzt der
anfang eines sehr sehr langen prozesses
das muss man auch sagen da wären jetzt
verschiedene kapitel geöffnet wenn es
wird verhandelt dann werden verschiedene
kapitel geöffnet und zu jedem dieser
kapitel ist dann wieder eine
einstimmigkeit der 27 eu mitgliedern
nötig das heißt das ist ja wie gesagt
ein anfangs signal aber ein sehr sehr
langer weg vielleicht mal zum vergleich
nord mazedonien ist auch
beitrittskandidat seit seit 17 jahren
das heißt dagegen noch jahre der
verhandlung vor der ukraine und der eu
mutmaßlich also auch das ist ein
berechtigter hinweis dass das also noch
eine weite wegstrecke ist ich lese
gerade mal einige kommentare vor von mak
er schreibt uns über youtube putin wird
nicht aufhören wenn er die ukraine
einnimmt ermuntert ihnen das nur wir
müssen die ukraine so gut mit allem
unterstützen wir können putin hat seine
globalen ziele ja deutlich genannt und
angela herrmann schreibt uns schwere
waffen und insbesondere kampfpanzer und
kampfjets sogar ihrer meinung nach für
die ukraine putin muss diesen krieg
verlieren so weit mal 2 stimmen hier bei
uns im netz natürlich gerne auch noch
mal der hinweis an euch uns wieder gerne
eure fragen und kommentare zuzuschicken
über zum beispiel die sozialen netzwerke
oder auch unsere e mail adresse bleiben
wir noch mal bei der innenpolitik ja wie
viel konfliktpotenzial hat das thema
waffenlieferungen auch insgesamt der
umgang mit der ukraine nach wie vor auch
innerhalb der ampel koalition dann auch
da gab es ja doch in den letzten wochen
unterschiedliche auffassungen wie
schnell und in welchem umfang man helfen
soll
ja was die waffenlieferung angeht ist ja
tatsächlich mehr herausgekommen oder
mehr zu sagen bekannt geworden als man
vorab dachte im grunde war im vorfeld
vermutet worden dass es vor allem um
diesen eu-beitritt geht da war dann doch
relativ konkret ist dabei was die waffen
angeht und das war auch eine forderung
die teile der ampel parteien hatten
heute morgen gab es ein interview von
ein gemeinsames interview von marie
agnes strack zimmermann von der fdp und
anderen hofreiter von den grünen die
haben noch mal gefordert schwere waffen
schnell und auch konkrete zusagen das
ist damit eingelöst das heißt die
sollten damit zufrieden sein aber klar
das ist weiterhin grosser
innenpolitischer konflikte bei die ampel
parteien da die union würde ich sagen an
ihrer seite wissen auch da gibt es ja
die forderung schnell schwere waffen das
was olaf scholz da jetzt angekündigt hat
die linke sieht das anders zumindest in
teilen in zivilen datel denn hat heute
gesagt das
sieht sie nicht sie möchte nicht weitere
waffenlieferungen sehen diese liste der
ukraine die wurde jetzt in den
vergangenen tagen häufig angesprochen
die ist ja auch enorm lang
da
sehr er eine politische liste muss man
sagen also ich glaube das ist gar nicht
zu erfüllen ich glaube oder scholz hat
mit diesen doch konkreten zusagen sich
luft verschafft und wie gesagt die
eigenen parteien in teilen auch
zufriedengestellt zumindest die dir sehr
laut gerufen haben die einschätzungen
unseres hauptstadt bernd weltin vielen
dank dankeschön nach berlin gerne und
wir sprechen noch mal mit brigitte
triebel von der konrad-adenauer-stiftung
leiterin des auslandsbüros in kharkiv
wie gesagt der zeit und heute dicht in
kharkiv sondern uns per skype
zugeschaltet aus deutschland nehme ich
mal stark an
betriebe wir haben gerade schon
gesprochen über die doch relativ
konkreten aussichten die es jetzt gibt
für die ukraine in bezug auf die eu ist
jetzt gerade noch mal den französischen
präsidenten auch hören können auch
bundeskanzler scholz hat sie diese
konkret heitz diese doch relativ ja
genaue zusage überrascht
ja ich würde sagen positiv überrascht ja
also ich
fand das jetzt sehr gut dass beide sehr
konkret geworden sind genau gesagt haben
was eben auch was ihr jetzt in nächster
zeit und so schnell wie möglich tun
werden wird wirklich der waffenlieferung
aber eben auch bezüglich des eu
beitritts der ukraine hat sich aber auch
interessant fand an beiden presse
statement das sie ja aufgegriffen wo
haben was in der ukraine aber auch in
der europäischen öffentlichkeit an ihren
aussagen und an ihrer politik in den
letzten wochen immer wieder kritisiert
worden also dass man kaum noch einmal
deutlich gesagt hat dass hier in der
ukraine ein kampf europas geführt wird
gegen dieses russische regime gegen
diesen russischen angriff ja das ist
ganz ganz wichtig für die ukraine das
ist aber auch ganz ganz wichtig für
unsere debatte in europa und auch dass
er das man kaum gesagt habe die ukraine
soll selber entscheiden wie dieser krieg
ein ende finden wird denn er gerade er
hatte sich ja noch mal in den letzten
wochen immer wieder mit äußerungen
ausgezeichnet dass man doch den
russischen präsidenten nicht genug
benötigen sollte dass man doch auch
darauf rücksicht nehmen sollte wie der
kreml denkt und fühlt das fand ich
interessant dass er das so prominent
aufgegriffen hat und dann noch einmal in
die ukraine signalisiert hat wir stehen
wirklich mit allem was wir haben hinter
der ich gerade eine nachfrage frau
triebel baum glauben sie denn dass man
das so prominent gemacht hat also warum
hat er nochmal was ja eigentlich für
jeden mehr oder weniger ersichtlich ist
dass am ende noch mal eine
verhandlungslösung kommen muss warum hat
er darauf noch mal so explizit
hingewiesen und auch darauf hingewiesen
dass russland oder das ist auch putin
sein gesicht nicht verlieren dürfe wie
schätzen sie das ein warum hat er das
getan
also ich denke dass er heute so deutlich
war war ein ganz klares zeichen der
solidarität für die ukraine und ich
denke auch ein deutliches zeichen
gegenüber moskau das ist hier eine euro
einheit gibt dass die ukraine nicht
verhandelbar ist dass er in den letzten
wochen durchaus auch andere äußerungen
getätigt hat sicherlich etwas mit dem
interesse auch in frankreich zu tun dass
man diesen krieg
womöglich zumindest schnell beenden
möchte und
auf in welcher form auch immer immer
noch davon ausgeht dass man in
gesprächen mit putin in verhandlungen
doch noch etwas erreichen kann
aber bei olaf scholz haben wir das eben
auch gesehen er hat ja auch noch einmal
die kritik an seiner politik in den
letzten wochen und monaten aufgegriffen
hat erklärt dass deutschland alles
gemacht hat seit dem kriegsausbruch er
hat auch noch mal erwähnt dass man mit
der eigenen staats tradition gebrochen
hat und nun was man liefert und nun auch
auf lange sicht ganz ganz wichtig für
die ukraine hinter diesem land steht
jetzt ist aber entscheiden dass diesen
worten wirklich taten folgen und dass
man weiterhin so geschlossen und auch so
klar gegenüber moskau auftritt wir haben
noch die eine oder andere user frage
friedrich fragt uns über youtube was
rechtfertigt denn einen eu beitritt der
ukraine oder einen eu beitritt von
moldau wie würden sie seine frage
beantworten natürlich gibt es da auch
noch skeptiker die sagen na ja da gibt
es gewisse formalitäten die ja auch
erfüllt sein müssen auch durchaus
inhaltlicher art was rechtsstaatlichkeit
und der korruptionsbekämpfung
angeht aber wie würden sie auf diese
frage antworten was würden sie sagen ist
das politische argument dafür ich würde
darauf antworten dass wir uns im moment
in einer ausnahmesituation befinden wir
haben krieg mitten in europa und das ist
kein ukraine krieg das ist ein krieg
russlands gegen unsere europäische werte
liegen unsere demokratien und gegen
unsere sicherheit unser europa basiert
aber auf einem sicherheitssystem und
auch unseren demokratischen strukturen
und wenn diese strukturen diese
gesellschaftsform in denen wir so gut
leben angegriffen werden dann müssen wir
auch außerordentlich handeln dann müssen
wir auch bestimmte kritik an ukraine die
völlig berechtigt ist wenn es um
rechtsstaatlichkeit geht oder um
korruption müssen wir die dürfen wir
nicht vergessen dürfen wir nicht
beiseiteschieben aber wir müssen
zumindest uns klar darüber sein dass die
ukraine zu europa gehört und moldau
ebenfalls weil moldau ist ähnlich
gefährdet wie die ukraine lange war und
jetzt sich in diesem krieg befindet also
es ist tatsächlich um den bundeskanzler
zu zitieren eine zeitenwende ist ein
historischer moment wo wir uns nicht nur
auf dieses kriterium zurückziehen können
und ich bin mir sicher es wird ein
langer prozess für die ukraine auch für
moldau und dann werden wird die eu auch
die forderungen stellen dass diese
länder tatsächlich funktionierende
demokratien werden und das ist ja gerade
der hebel mit dem man so viel erreichen
kann in diesem starken
der ukrainische präsident selensky hat
im vorfeld zumindest öfter davon
gesprochen dass deutschland eben ein
klares bekenntnis zur ukraine geben
müsse nicht einen spagat versuchen
dürfte zwischen kiew einerseits und
moskau andererseits hatten sie da das
gefühl er misstraut der bundesregierung
da immer noch so ein wenig
ja dieses misstrauen wird hört man immer
wieder nicht nur vom ukrainischen
präsidenten das wird man aus den
ministerien oder auch im ganzen land und
meinen gesprächen begegnet mir dass mehr
er hat immer noch angst dass deutschland
aus wirtschaftsinteressen auch aus dem
dänen diesen krieg schnell zu beenden
dann doch zu verhandlungen auf kosten
der ukraine bereit ist das ist deswegen
war diese klare äußerung von olaf scholz
jetzt gerade so richtig es ist jetzt
aber genauso wichtig dass deutschland
frankreich aber auch italien diese
führung in europa tatsächlich übernehmen
und die solidarität ohne abstriche für
die ukraine auch in den nächsten wochen
zeigen denn was klar ist die nächsten
wochen und monate werden ganz ganz
schwer für die ukraine militärisch und
sie werden aber auch entscheidend für
diesen krieg seien letzte frage dazu
weil es auch gerade angesprochen haben
also verhandlungen über abtretungen von
gebiet der ukraine mit russland das ist
ja offenbar
absolutes no go für die ukraine
jedenfalls für die große mehrheit dort
oder wie sehen sie das also ist daran
überhaupt zu denken dass die ukrainische
bevölkerung und eben auch die
ukrainische führung bereit wäre über
derlei dinge zu verhandeln
tatsächlich ist das ein no-go erst heute
morgen hatte ich gespräche mit unseren
partnern in der östlichen ukraine die
rechte an der front sind und die sagen
wir haben so opfer im moment und es ist
so dramatisch all das zu sehen und zu
erleben aber klar ist wir werden keinen
einzigen meter
preisgeben denn aus ukrainischer sicht
ist die lage klar egal was man russland
jetzt gibt welchen teil dieses
territoriums was übrigens sehr viel ist
im moment sind 20 der ukraine russisch
besetzt das wird kein ende des krieges
bedeuten das wird nur höchstens eine
atempause bedeuten die russland
womöglich nutzt um weitere angriffe auf
die ukraine vorzubereiten denn aus
ukrainischer perspektive ist klar
russland zählt auf die komplette
kontrolle des gesamten landes und da
wird
das sieht man jetzt im moment einfach
keinen sinn darin irgend etwas
herzugeben irgendwelche konzessionen zu
machen und ich kann auch nur davor
warnen das zu tun einmal weil ich auch
nicht davon ausgehe dass russland sich
mit dem don was zufriedengeben wird das
wird nicht passieren das ziel ist die
sogenannte den artifiziellen und die
militarisierung der gesamten ukraine und
wir sehen dass wir russland in den
besetzten gebieten fordert es ist eine
vernichtung der ukraine und der
ukrainische nation die wir leider dort
beobachten müssen und so ist es aus der
ukrainischen perspektive nachvollziehbar
dass sie bereit sind diese opfer zu
zahlen und deswegen war es eben denke
ich auch so wichtig dass gerade machen
doch einmal gesagt hat das ist die
ukrainische entscheidung aber es sollte
eben auch das ziel der europäer sein
dass wir jetzt die russische führung in
ihrem angriffskrieg eindämmen und
zurückdrängen denn wenn wir das nicht
tun dann wird es nie einen wird es in
nächster zeit kein wasser stillstand
aber auch kein frieden für ganz europa
gehen denn wenn der donbass dieser
donners kampf im moment und diese
gefechte
aus russischer sicht positiver verlaufen
also erfolgreich sein werden dann müssen
wir damit rechnen dass weitere offensiv
wie möglich wieder auf die hauptstadt
kiew geplant werden und das wird so
weitergehen bis wir russland bis der
preis für russland so hoch ist dass sie
wirklich bereit sind ernsthafte
verhandlungen zu geben
soweit die einschätzungen von brigitta
triebe von der konrad-adenauer-stiftung
ukraine experten kann man so sagen ich
danke ihnen ganz herzlich für das
gespräch und ihre analysen heute hier
bei uns danke sehr
und so weiter unser live stream zum
besuch des bundeskanzlers in der ukraine
also man hat sich ausgesprochen sowohl
deutschland als auch italien als auch
frankreich für ein jahr was den
eu-kandidatenstatus
der ukraine an geht alles weitere dazu
dann in den nächsten tagen wir werden
das natürlich weiter für euch verfolgen
1 wollen einen schönen abends danke für
euer interesse fürs mitmachen und bis
zum nächsten mal toto